NFC Player of the Year in the
Philadelphia Eagles Hall of Fame
five-time NFC championship games in his
career the all-time leader in
Philadelphia Eagles pass attempts
completions yards and passing touchdowns
but for the moment as he pointed out
soccer dad yes that's me
Donovan J McNabb yes and the in the
house in the house Syracuse is in the
house right now
Syracuse is definitely in the house were
deep I know that I gotta tell you I was
just talking moments ago about how we
kind of first met over Eagles cam on NFL
Total Access I would fire up Eagles camp
for you I was first introduced to the
magic of John Donovan Jay McNabb when
you ran without shoes into the end zone
and the big house didn't absolutely
stuck it to my wolf yeah how did you
feel about that I was pissed like best
guy I've never heard of all due respect
from Syracuse is gonna run in the big
house without shoes on and beat the
Wolverines did you purposely take untie
your shoes for that no just to show the
shoe just happened to fly off you it was
funny you bring that up because I was
the first to for my shoes to kind of
come off or explode before Zion did it
this past year unfortunately I was
rewarded with a hundred million dollar
contract you know so I guess they they
went with Velcro I think after that or
you know just unfortunately just it work
for me just adds to the legend it I'm
glad you brought it up because now
people go back and watch the VHS they
was September 12 1998 mmm so it was
early on that really that's back in the
day well no I think you guys have lost a
Notre Dame in their first week and then
we came in and just yeah more fuel to
the fire I will tell you that was back
in the day was that pre that's pre BCS
right that was the first year the BCS
first year the BCS we're all together
cuz Don we got jobs at home against
Tennessee that absolutely thank you
absolutely
the phantom passing the fears code on
peerless price get out of here your list
price oh yeah good
names were thrown out right now tee
Martin was a Tennessee quarterback okay
it's enough Syracuse how did you wind up
at Syracuse how did you get there I was
recruited by Paul Pascal oniy Kevin
Rogers offense was very similar they
came out Chicago to recruit a young
young kid out of Mount Carmel High
School that they thought would be able
to carry the torch for Marvin graves
that have been able to kind of light for
me and his name was Donovan McNabb yes
like five tradition by the way I thought
you're about to go third-person on me
right there no thought you're gonna go
and make dick they pulled Donovan out of
Chicago I wasn't a Samuel Jackson though
so you go to Syracuse yes all right
we all remember your draft tag mm-hmm it
was exciting you know everybody wants to
talk about the boos but I look I look
beyond that you know it was an exciting
time for me you know it was the first
the first chapter in the book of dogs
that had a hurt though I mean as much is
because I've never been booed so I
didn't know what was going on what he
won or Ricky Williams - yeah yeah Ricky
was a great guy I know he did some great
days in college now this is at Radio
City Music Hall right yes so they drove
all the way up the turnpike just to boo
you that's ridiculous hey it's
unfortunate things happen I know but
then you went out and did what you did
with Andy Reid for sure what would you
say is the the the pinnacle of your time
in Philadelphia Donovan you know what it
was it was finally getting over to Hoff
and making it to the Super Bowl
you know we had battled so much NFC
Championship NFC Championship win any
NFC East and finally getting over the
hump that I think is the was a pinnacle
for all of us at that particular time
what did Andy Reid do for you what was
your relation he allowed me to be myself
but he then so many so many coaches they
draft their quarterbacks and make the
robotic you know this is the this is the
way that it's been run it's it's been
proven that it works we have to do this
this there's no Andy allowed me to come
in learn the offense and he said hey you
know what are you comfortable that you
understand we're doing now I want you to
be you if one's there throw it if one's
not there 2 is not there 3 is not there
use your legs and as we continue to
progress the
maturity offense then we can kind of get
creative at times you know 1 2 3 is not
there hey I move go back to 3 see if one
is available and then we started to play
a little playground football who is the
most talented guy you played with
probably it's time for you know we have
the Brian westbrook's
obviously you know what teo brought to
us we have some great offensive linemen
on the defensive end Brian Dawkins Jevon
Kearse Jeremiah Trotter the list goes on
but I would just say it's hard to say
but when you have a weapon behind you
that not only can run the football
pickup blitzes and catch the football on
their back field that's an added
dimension that every quarterback would
love to have it's interesting Donovan
McNabb here in their charge of what you
just described what an eery did for you
it just seems like it's being replicated
with my homes he's I mean wouldn't talk
about guys throwing with his left what
all ago no look throwing and just in his
second season and he's Fanny's first
full as the as a starter right yes it
just seems that that's what McNabb is I
mean that's what you know Reid is seeing
and moans and he's doing right now it's
funny you bring up Patrick mahomes
because some of the things that he's
he's been doing at this particular point
he did a little bit of a little Texas
Tech you know from scrambles and throw
under 65 70 yards downfield right where
everyone said oh that's just not
football well when you see it on the
center stage and Tariq Hill or Travis
Kelce Kareem hunt the list goes on a
guys that are on the other end of it now
you start to appreciate his game a
little bit more right I mean and I think
we've seen it so much from the Randall
Cunningham to the Michael Vick's the
list goes on of all the mobile
quarterbacks Aaron Rodgers does it
himself but when Aaron does it it's all
it's beautiful it's like poetry in
motion
mm-hmm when when Patrick does it it's
like aa display ground football no it's
the same thing it just has a little bit
more pizzazz to it so you live in
Phoenix now so you had a front row seat
obviously to the calimary selection by
the Arizona Cardinals yeah do you think
he's gonna pan out in the NFL I believe
there's a three-year process and I say
the three-year process maybe Steve
calves not there for the whole whole
duration but I think they have to build
from within for him to be successful
that means up front have some have
some pretty good blockers in a passing
game and also be able to run the
football with David Johnson give him a
weapon on the outside besides Larry
Fitzgerald I love Larry that's like my
brother
my younger brother but at this point
almost like a turtle well they also
moved him inside pretty well too that's
when you need someone on the outside
well like a Christian Kirk and they date
they they drafted a whole bunch of kids
we'll see which one might be able to
take the top off here yeah but I mean
you need to get a vet who has proven
that he can get off press coverage and
create separation if you do that it
opens up everything else in the middle
field for Larry and then with that with
that said what are you gonna have on
defense you know are you gonna have any
pass rusher besides Chandler Jones is he
anybody gonna get to the quarterback
well someone else now that Patrick
Peterson to be out for a couple games
will they step up and be a threat in a
secondary but I'm just talking about
Kyler Murray but it all works together
because right now we're focusing just on
the quarterback yeah but it's a total
team effort for a young guy I mean Josh
Rosen was getting hit in the face at
seven eight times a game that's a fact
but he doesn't have the ability to
escape in the same way that Carla me
what is shitty about that that's a bonus
you know if you can start play from the
pocket and get the ball out of your
hands and complete passes downfield to
move the chains now on defense they get
you the ball back now all of a sudden
that quarterback looks a little little
different is that the way you viewed it
when you came out for Syracuse off Randy
Reed down yes yes and that was the thing
that I always argue with Annie every
year during the draft and he will go out
and get some of the fat guys he would go
out and get an offensive lineman and Eli
but the thing that he explained to me
was I'm gonna protect you and make sure
I get the ball back for you right and
then you can do your thing but if you're
constantly on your back oh you're
running around in circles back there
it's not making that neither one of us
look good
Donald McNabb here in the Rich Eisen
show speaking of three year plans mm-hmm
you don't mind me please let's break it
down in this direction
oh no the blessed glasses around is
Carson Wentz on a three-year plan
according to you Donna McNabb well that
wouldn't be a decision that I would have
to make that's a decision Anthony well
they picked up his option and he's
cleared now for football activities yes
if he stays healthy this year
we see the Carson that we've seen when
he's healthy mm-hmm great things can
happen in Philadelphia you know if
something happens then I'm sure they'll
go back to my comments this summer of
what if but I think when he's healthy
Carson is one of the best young
quarterbacks in the game mm-hmm
no I'm I see that I want to read what
you said please please I think
personally if he can't get out of the
second round in the next two maybe three
years but really two years to be honest
Rudy if he can't get out of the second
round they should look to possibly draft
another quarterback because you just
don't know about his durability
durability caress yes so let me think
about this the last two seasons your
backup quarterback is taking you to a
Super Bowl for winning MVP and then
possibly back to the NFC Championship
with the same team that you have now if
he's healthy and they get out of the
first round then that's good for him but
what happens in that next year if he's
out stood in the first round who are we
pointing the finger at you know I've
played the position it's them
it's you played that position in that
City - yes it's not your point here I
have experiences of being there and it's
just the nature of the business it's
nothing against Carson I love Carson I
love his game when he's healthy he's one
of the best in the game you know but
that's just the way it is I mean if
you're not healthy think about this if
Andrew Luck wasn't able to come back
after the shoulder injury you think the
Indianapolis Coast was not drafted a
quarterback of course they would have
right so why would it be any different
for anywhere well because Karl let me
get into it because Carson Wentz is a
different first of all it's a back and
it's a knee it's not a shoulder so but
it is still an injury it's an injury
which is your point yeah okay so now
that's two years in a row where he has
not been able to play in the playoffs or
answer the bell however you want to
however you're finish the season
correct and so to basically say right
now that he's on notice for the next two
or three years is is a reasonable way of
looking at it
we'll say that mm-hmm but it's also a
way of maybe stirring the pot in the
city where he's beloved in a way that
perhaps but the pot is already 2/3 so
that that's why I'm bringing this up as
well in this regard is some of the
Eagles folks there did not take kindly
to your comment what you know what's
funny this is the conversation that's
been going on for the last year and a
half because majority of those fans out
there fairly really want to Nick back
they were upset when when they decided
not to bring Nick back now I felt like
this was the opportunity for Carson to
come in and take his team back over you
think they should have brought Nick
Foles back no cuz I mean no because it's
time it's time to get paid that's not
all it is and you can pay a back up like
that true so maybe then your sense is
that they should have made Nick the
starter no what I'm saying is this is a
great opportunity for Carson mm-hmm
because I knew they were gonna move on
with Nick Nick Doody he was gonna easily
have to move but this is a great
opportunity for Carson to regain his
team back look at all the all the things
that were going on and talked about in
the locker room talking about his
leadership and how arrogant he was
things like that starts to pick up
inside and it carries outside for us to
even talk about it as media may be
talking about Wentz Waits
well a lot of people said that that was
false so why would it even come out I
don't know see that's the thing so many
people pounded the table for Carson when
they said that and they should his
teammates should but it still was out
there you know think about it I mean I'm
not saying anything that nobody else has
said I know but you're Donovan McNabb
was played in Philadelphia for all those
years and that's what I think people are
saying is that you're you should be a
cheerleader here but the reason why I'm
bringing up is that there's two ways
looking at yeah he's injury prone he
hasn't been able to finish the season
for two straight years and any other
quarterback in any other situation you
know what you got to start thinking
about what this guy's viability is
moving long term certainly if you're
putting all the eggs in the basket when
you had
Super Bowl MVP and you let him walk to
Jacksonville to get paid that's one way
to look at another way is like you know
what those injuries were just two
unfortunate things he dove for the
endzone he shouldn't be doing that
anymore he'll be a little bit better the
back I have no earthly idea what
happened I don't think anybody does
right now those are just things that
happen in the NFL you can get hurt but
he's really supremely talented and
they're gonna go and they're gonna go
back to the Super Bowl with him I
believe they can okay
I believe they can represent the NFC's
and I represent the NFC but he has to be
healthy I don't think that they will be
able to do that without him being
healthy Don of McNabb here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you think of Brady
being able to play as long as he has
Drummond am i you know not ice cream but
you know breeze is closing in
potentially on 20 years right now in the
NFL and it's it's one to be said for
Drew Brees we've seen Tom and Tom looks
amazing and he's done a great job but
for Drew Brees
I mean he's battled injury remember he
battled the shoulder injury in fact well
then and then obviously that was what
led him to not go to Miami I go to Miami
end up with sharp pain right and he's
continuously put up great numbers at the
age of he's playing it
I commend Drew I thought he probably
would would say that it was his last
year after last year but I give him a
lot of credit for the way he's been
playing and they're actually still a
tough tough match to go against with
chimera I thought they would have kept
Ingram but they decided to go in another
direction their defense I mean they
still get past pass rushers right and
guys in the secondary that can make
plays for them so Sean Payton has done a
great job with with the New Orleans
Saints yeah it's just amazing again that
Brady is 42 and does not seem to have
lost a single step
nothing it's amazing it's amazing and I
remember years ago I said it on my radio
show and I was working with with with
the ESP I said he was the goat you know
I'm Joe Montana he and Joe Montana been
battling but he's proven at this age to
still play at this elite level that he's
the greatest of all time so
what do you think your numbers would be
if you were able to play in today's game
not that great you don't think so I mean
the game has changed a little bit and
I'm old you know I've taken some hits
and I'm I've got the day I you know
right now but I just I committed him
it's it's always one in a bunch yeah
when you look at the older guys who are
kind of retired and moved on to say man
if I still play it I would be no Thomas
Thomas just that guy what about in your
prime I'm playing with Reid as a head
coach yes yes who do I have on the
outside mmm
teal younger tea oh no though I guess
the one that that you played on play
with yeah yeah - the drama you
understand I mean because the we came on
the show a few years ago said the two of
you guys were okay you saw him what you
have I mean I've always been okay I've
said that he was a first-ballot
hall-of-famer I've always stood up for
it said they now he'll make some
comments out of it you know unordinary
but I'm not gonna go back and forth and
with that but you know I appreciate him
coming over and playing with it with us
you know I just gotta love it at that
I mean his his Super Bowl performance
with you guys was pretty remarkable he
did a great job here II had back in play
well mm-hmm yes but do you think the off
the field stuff really affected
everything that's the that's what has
put people kind of in a different light
when it comes to his name it's the off
the field stuff it's the things that he
says the attention that he draws on the
football field one of the best to ever
do it but it's just everything else that
kind of goes with it that's all and you
could choose the two receivers then you
choose him um just anybody that I've
ever played with no how about right now
you're a prime McNabb five
from my NFL total axes first couple
years eagles cam you were in the middle
of being the annual quarterback in the
NFC to try and make it to the Super Bowl
right including that one you were you
made it right you get to choose two
receivers in today's game in today's
game yes sir I'm gonna run him back
I'll take Brian Westbrook your running
back from from today's game you take
today's game take Westbrook get running
back you know I probably would he was
amazing that he was able to do
I mean chimera chimera is kind of
similar in so many ways to Brian
Westbrook but I would take the Brian
Westbrook okay and then receivers I mean
I would still take my 2004 but I love
Travis Kelce a tight in I love wood you
know even though he's kind of going
through some issues with tarik he'll you
know they because he's like DeSean
Jackson when he was in our office and
then probably I would but if I couldn't
have tio tonight you might as well have
someone like him and put Odell back
about it cuz he is I can't wait to see
what Odell looks like in Cleveland this
year though I think he is and he's he's
got a chip for Baker Mayfield by the way
if he can keep them all healthy they
lead the league and chips but Mayfield
and Jarvis and him right that's I mean
there's gonna be there chip that's a lot
of conversation draw to you by Pringles
and members of the media should have a
fun time interview I know right great to
have you on Donovan
let me know whenever you're in town come
on and come back in here you know I
would love to come back in and do some
things which you don't that would be an
honor thank you I appreciate you being
here thanks for coming back you know
what yeah I'm just gonna take a couple
days off like the Golden State Warriors
and relax and get back healthy
I remember you played who did you play
with it Syracuse what ed hoops
there's anyone on your team John Wallace
you are 90 16 with the national
championship game okay though
so we're pretty big with that but
Carmelo was he's a little younger than
anything that they I'm still doing it
unbelievable unbelievable if they never
took his wins away he I think he
probably would've retired you think so
huh yeah you agree with that Chris over
he was a very spiteful guy runs the
Syracuse family huh
okay Donovan J McNabb on Twitter is
super underscore number five with IV e
afterwards on Instagram good to see you
sir thank you for having hi to your
lovely family that's not bad that's
Donna McNabb here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app